but you know who's not getting rewarded
right now
republican senator lindsey graham
last week
in the state of south carolina the
aitkin county republican party
voted to censure
republican senator lindsey graham
now so far this year when we have seen
republicans come out and censure their
own members usually it's because they've
either said they don't agree with donald
trump's big lie
or they've you know well pretty much
it's only been if they uh aren't blindly
loyal to trump so did lindsey graham do
something we don't know about
no
it's actually much worse than that what
lindsey graham's crime is according to
this aitkin county republican party in
their censure
he voted to allow the infrastructure
bill to move forward
and they censored him for it
just because he voted to allow the thing
to move forward and then of course he
praised the bipartisan infrastructure
bill the trillion dollar bill
praised it so it's a good thing
but in today's republican party
it's not only that you have to be
blindly loyal to trump but now it's you
can't even vote
on a bipartisan piece of legislation
without facing backlash from your party
because if that's the case
we're doomed
and this country is doomed
because that's what this is this is a
bipartisan infrastructure bill that
should go much further than it does but
you know we've got the three and a half
trillion bill coming up behind it
hopefully reconciliation will get that
going but either way
this is a bill that is broadly supported
across america by republicans and
democrats and independents everybody
majority of them
support this and they want this piece of
legislation because they know that
infrastructure means jobs
infrastructure means work infrastructure
means investments
in local economies
but apparently the folks over at the
aitkin county republican party didn't
get that memo
and they voted to censure him
is this a new era
have we finally
entered the era here in the united
states where neither party can vote with
the other one on a piece of legislation
where everything has to be so damn
kindergarten black and white with these
people where if it's not a republican
bill you have to vote against it even if
republicans worked on it like with the
infrastructure bill
nope republicans always have to vote
together and democrats always all have
to vote together tribalism is killing us
here in the united states
the two-party system tribalism is
killing us here in the united states
this infrastructure package is decades
overdue folks
and because lindsey graham actually said
yeah this is a good thing he gets
punished for it by these aiken county
republicans
that's just nuts
and there's no other way to say that
this is ridiculous we cannot allow our
country to get to the point where there
is no
bipartisanship allowed where there's no
negotiations allowed
because if we ever truly hit that point
which apparently is where the aitkin
county republicans want us to go then
we're done that's it pack it up
start something new because america is
not going to continue to function
if we ever hit that point where these
aitkin county republicans clearly want
to take us